he's standing Sheridan long long time
handicapper sports analyst for USA Today
also a contributor to cigar aficionado
he's been asked to be the keynote
speaker at the annual meeting of the
College Football Association in April
his talk will be on sports betting got a
recent column in Cigar Aficionado
magazine five rules of Super Bowl
betting which we'll get to Danny good
morning how are you good morning and I
want to congratulate you on being
selected to the National Sports Media
Association Hall of Fame because I
remember you when you would CNN sports
but you been against me getting into the
Hall of Fame well the odds were a
longshot when I do that Wilde and
Patrick in the 80s at CNN in Atlanta yes
I would have bet against you all right
you're gonna talk to the College
Football Association about sports
betting what is that I'm really honoured
about that shows you how times have
changed in the ever since sport well
this would have never happened if sports
betting
we're not legalized in May of 2018 by
the Supreme Court but yeah there's a lot
of people don't understand sports
betting and they think that games can be
fixed and oh now that it's legalized
it's Sodom and Gomorrah anyway yes I'm
looking forward to it and I'm really a
very very flattered that they asked me
why is it legal down in a lot of states
what happened well what happened is we
got out of the eighteen hundred's of the
1700s I would ask you and I have before
on the show why can the people of Nevada
bet on sports where it's legal and the
people of New York
Alabama etc can't it's just insanity and
everyone from you know Europe you can
bet on our presidential election by the
way you can't bet on our presidential
election here but in Europe as you know
you can bet on sports you can bet on
sports our sports in Canada it's crazy
so finally the Supreme Court decided to
hear it and said it makes no sense I
mean murders not legal in any state but
betting is legal in Nevada why can't the
rest of them do it and that's a
garrulous answer yeah I'm just trying to
figure out where we're headed with this
and and I I always tell people that you
know we look at officiating and right
now we can look at officiating we might
not
like it all of a sudden when it's
legalized betting and there's more money
on these games and like worst case
scenario here you know it could be bad
because we're holding people accountable
here and it feels like these leagues are
running out of excuses you have you know
the cheating scandal with the Houston
Astros we've had calls that weren't
overturned in the NFL when they're
obvious they're you know basketball it
looks like the star players get star
treatment
I don't know how far it goes Danny but
what concerns do you have with those
scenarios well first of all I don't have
any concerns because let's just say that
a referee we're going to fix a game what
is he going to do he's got a bet on it
Dan you me a referee you cannot bet that
kind of money without raising a red flag
and the safeguards are in place when
betting was when sports betting came in
I guess in 1940 when the point spread
was invented it's been the same thing
even though it's legalized now it's even
harder to fix a bet if you walk in Dan
or just say brother Todd Fritz walks in
and he wants to bet $5,000 which is a
lot of money but not a lot of money if
you're going to fix a game and he wants
to bet it legally in New Jersey
it's going to raise a red flag it's
obviously going to raise a red flag with
your bookmaker if you bet $500 a game
and all of a sudden you'd like to bet
$50,000 mm-hmm dan patrick has a great
line of credit at his local bank let's
say you have make up a figure Dan 25,000
and you walk in you want to borrow a
million dollars you're going to raise
some red flags so you're going to get
caught if you try to fix a game and
whenever there's a bad call or like the
Astros cheating no one capitalized on it
imbedding if they did they'd be caught
when an inordinate amount of money shows
up on a game it's generally fixed and
real quickly the Tulane betting scandal
those guys were betting the college
students $25 a game you remember the
Tulane band yeah Connor it with Hundley
anyway $25 a game they call their
bookmaker locally and said hey we want
to go to $50 a game they went well
that's a red flag for that bookmaker in
New Orleans but no big deal then they
wanted to post up a few hundred dollars
he
cut him off he notified Vegas because it
was not legal he couldn't call the US
attorney there and say hey these guys
are fixing games thank you sir what do
you do oh I'm an illegal bookmaker he
had to call it silly you had to call
Nevada tell them they told the New
Orleans DA and that's how the case was
uncovered an inordinate amount of money
which was only $25 to a hundred it's a
phenomenal they do it they being the
bookmakers and I'm not saying they're
choirboys but they do a wonderful job of
keeping the sport clean because it's in
their interest and then you had the Josh
Shaw situation where the Cardinals DB
who wasn't playing but then he goes to a
sports book and then he bets on the
Cardinals well they were worried that
but it wasn't like he wasn't betting
against his team I'm not going to pass
judgment obviously shouldn't do it but
you have owners that probably bet I'm
not going to mention any names they
certainly gamble in Vegas but that's
again he didn't bet like I don't know
what he bad but it wasn't much money
again he didn't bet against his team if
you want to bet on your team I don't
want to minimize it but betting against
your team is a no-no I have no problems
that Pete Rose bet on his team but maybe
I'm in the minority but I would have a
major problem if an athlete ever bet
against his team regardless of the
reason and you would - yeah I would but
I have a problem with Pete betting on
his team to win because you can
manipulate a lineup there and you can
use it like your reliever and you're
gonna put him in there this is very
correct what you said but does that
guarantee that you'll win the game he
lost money betting with his knowledge
with is if you want to use the word
manipulating the line of you he lost
money it's very hard to beat the spread
Dan it really is and again if you don't
if you're betting on your team how can
you how can well I guess you know a
coach could run up the score a
professional coach or a college coach
but why would he do that
when he's making millions and if he did
it how would he bet that kind of money
he couldn't bet twenty thousand dollars
or ten thousand dollars without raising
a bell and I do know of coaches and I'm
writing a book now who have made wagers
when well they were out of coaching and
they were athlete
directors well-known all the fame
coaches and they took the bet because it
was on their team talking to Danny
Sheridan the handicapper sports analysts
for USA Today also contributor to a
cigar aficionado I also think that your
bookies they're gonna still exist
because it feels like like I don't want
my money the government knowing how much
money I want like taxes are still going
to play into this right Danny that's an
excellent point Dan and I'm glad you
raised it and I wish others would raise
it it's not going to affect illegal
bookies one iota if Dan and Danny like
to bet $200 a week or whatever with our
offshore bookmaker or our bookmaker down
the street we don't want the government
knowing about it
what legalized betting is doing is
unleashing this PIN of demand of people
that like to bet on sports they like to
watch it and they like to bet on it so
they take fritzy I guess he has a son
hopefully he's not corrupted he's in
high school he probably bets with his
friends well now that he goes to college
he'll be able to bet legally or when
he's 21 and that's what it's doing it's
bringing a new generation of betters who
saw their parents bet with illegal
bookmakers and they're betting with
legal bookmakers then New Jersey just
passed as you know they passed legalized
sports betting in May of 18
started taking bets legal sports bets
New Jersey in June today
over five billion dollars in bets a year
and a half later four billion in bets
just the first 11 months of 2018
tremendous demand out there but your
point is great no it's not going to
affect illegal bookmakers one iota it
won't drive business away from them
alright let's talk about this Super Bowl
if people are betting on it the line is
now one and at what point do you jump on
the line it's one and a half for the
Chiefs giving one and a half yeah it's
one and a half and the total is 54 and
if you're an underdog better you're
obviously waiting to see if it goes up
if you want to bet on the favorite
you're betting the first week eight or
nine days you'll bet the favorite so
that's pretty much what betters do and
then a total there well how can I have
to worry about whether I don't think
they're going to have to worry about
people that bet the total which is the
second-biggest bet combined scores
they'll wait until the day of the game
and by the way 90 probably 92 to 95
percent of the money the billions the 14
or 13 billion that will be illegally bet
on the Super Bowl will be bet Saturday
and Sunday the day before the game not
now and you're not big on prop bets
either right why oh it's insanity that
as I mentioned in the article bookmakers
in Vegas and across the world that I've
talked to have told me that only twice
in the last 24 years has the public won
money betting on propositions the public
bets everything over Dan like the
quarterback will have over 200 yards
passing so if you have a high-scoring
quarter about high-scoring Super Bowl
like you did two years ago with
Philadelphia and New England then it's
everything's going to go over the public
one during that Super Bowl and you have
to go back I can't remember the date the
80s the public won a ton of money the
idea of betting William the refrigerator
Perry to score a touchdown 12 to 1 odds
down the kickoff which was two-to-one
odds however they want a lot of money on
that Prop but they lost overall it's
just insanity and 500 props you can bet
everything the only thing I don't bet
and I don't think you bet on sports but
the only thing that you should bet on is
the point spread and the over and under
that's it
also when it comes to betting and your
philosophy do you do you have a formula
that you look at when it comes to
betting the Superbowl yes and I
mentioned in the article I just picked
the team I don't care if the Lions 14
what and it's not in the Super Bowl but
whatever and by the way the Super Bowl
line has only been I was looking it up
earlier it's been no higher than like
five or five and a half the last 10
Super Bowls for whatever that's worth
but what I do is I just picked the
winner the winner is won this game and
beaten the spread eighty eight percent
of the time and 57 percent of the time
against the spread is an outstanding
record so you've got six Super Bowls it
was in USA Today might just add I just
mentioned to you today in their sports
line but yeah just picked the winner
obviously this one's a real close line
one one and a half it could go up
and on the total Dan and this may sound
contrarian and I give the reasons for it
but if you have two offensive juggernaut
like last year you had the number one
and number two scoring teams in the
conference in the NFL with San Francisco
excuse me with the Rams in New England I
take the game under two offensive
juggernauts
I go under it went well under the total
two defensive star wars I go over that
may sound contrarian but I give the
reasons and it certainly held me my
philosophy is to bet against calling cow
herds pick and I'm and I'm rolling this
year so no will you be in really good
shape what I've read you've been real
good a very knowledgeable man but you'd
be in very good shape he put me on his
show a few years ago he was disagreeing
with me and he could certainly be right
in this case he wasn't he said Ohio
State would this as many years ago maybe
six or seven they would lose too they
would not lose the game I told him they
would lose two games we made a thousand
dollar bet for charity and they lost two
games like I said so I guess I was lucky
he's a very knowledgeable and excellent
host but he I would say what a based on
what I've read he doesn't have a strong
opinion on the point spread overall
Danny good to talk to you always a
pleasure
you like to Chiefs don't you know I'm
like I really won't decide and I would
say if I liked him I'm not a shame to
tell you but no just like I wrote in the
article I'm gonna wait until the night
to the last minute but I usually make my
decision on Sunday and exactly what I've
written is what's helping me to be
successful and handicapping the game
wait how much will you bet I don't bet
man I pick games do that okay no that's
another thing I think I have an
advantage well I've been lucky over the
years is because I don't bet and I have
an objective opinion and if I'm wrong
it's my fault it's not the coaches fault
or the referees fault so that's why I
don't bet and I remember using a guy
called the professor oh good I had it I
I subscribed to at out service yeah and
it felt like they would give me one team
and then somebody else called in and
they give them the opposite I don't know
how that worked but I remember one year
betting on NFL games I had at out sir
I think it was called the professor
another one was called Big Apple or
something and I'd call into this number
and I'd say what's you know what's your
pick and and then they'd say we like the
Bears given the points and that would be
a click and that was it so you you paid
like $50 for each each week or something
crazy like that they call them I don't
know about the gentleman you're talking
about but they're call them scandi
cappers and yes many of them given both
sides and if we had more time I tell you
about they got such great scams like
I'll give you one real quick Daniel hug
me off if you're running late okay Dan
you call me and I'll give you a free
pick there's no charge don't pay me to
you win yeah yeah that sounds great
of course you know what I'm leading to
so 200 people call and they give them
they will give them a free pick and
they'll give a hundred one side hundred
the other 100 people are happy then they
say hey don't pay me anymore dan Patrick
you want to know I'm gonna pick you
another free winner 50 people be right
if you'd be wrong now they've got two
winners they go this guy's great they
get down to about twenty or thirty
courts they start with a thousand and
they say to you you're gonna have to pay
ten thousand dollars or five thousand
this pick and you've gone for Andoh or
five and oh and you go this guy's the
greatest with that I'm out of rest and I
really appreciate you having me on
Thank You bunny it's great to talk to
you my stuff is always and thank you
thank you congratulations again on your
selection to the National Sports Media
Association Hall of Fame that's a great
honor
thank you it's Danny Sheraton USA Today
bedding guru there for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]